are you prepared to call h a terror
group is it possible to have a rational
I've asked you two questions should Hass
stay in power and are they a terror
group you're refusing to answer either
of them that is very telling talk TV is
the only place where you get the truth
you've done a book on poetry poetry and
music for the many I love poetry we can
agree on
that on TV
on Radio and on your smartphone this is
talk
[Music]
TV tonight on PE Morgan
uncensored Oris Johnson blusters his
long awaited appearance at the Co inquir
in his normal style but will it help the
country avoid repeating his deadly
mistakes we'll debate that and the
future of the government as immigration
Minister Robert jenrich sensationally
quits tonight over the Rwanda plan
Hollywood heavyweight John litz has been
scathing about the rise in anti-Semitism
since Israel's war on Hamas began
including he says some other Hollywood
Jews who join me live as will Israel's
ambassador to the UK and Taylor Swift is
named times person of the year is she
now the greatest pop star of all time
we'll
debate live from London this is Pi's
Morgan
uncensored well good evening welcome uh
to P Morgan uncensored live from my home
in London I still got covid but the show
will still go on uh it's just uncensored
with a dash of covid now there are many
valid criticisms about the UK
government's covid inquiry it's too long
far too expensive and too knoted up in
retrospective weeds to do what is
supposed to be doing working out if
we're better prepared for a pandemic now
than we were in 2020 and they're all
fair points but what I don't buy is the
spin that we've been shoveled by Boris
Johnson's acolytes ever since it started
they want us to believe it's another
anti- Boris Witch Hunt a show trial it's
not and if it was a show trial the judge
would be tossing him in the cells for
contempt of court Boris Johnson quit as
an MP after lying to
Parliament about his pandemic parties at
number 10 today he promised us this by
almighty
God that the evidence I shall give be
the truth shall be the truth the whole
truth and nothing but the
truth of course that turned out to be
his first lie Mrs how explained the
Curious Case of the 5,000 missing
WhatsApp messages on his phone from The
crucial early stages of the pandemic
that all just mysteriously
vanished do you know why your phone was
missing those 5,000 odd whatsapps I I
don't know the the exact reason but it
looks as though it's something to do
with the app going down and then uh
coming up
again um
but somehow uh
not automatically erasing all the things
uh
between that date when when it went down
and the moment when it was last backed
up
what a load of absolute cobblers have
you ever ever met anyone where that's
happened to them with their
whatsapps but Boris Johnson spent his
entire lifetime being economical with
the truth and yet somehow he's still
completely terrible at it under pressure
he became like a house of cards in front
of a fan here he is strenuously denying
he'd ever received an exasperated
message from his top civil servant only
for Hugo Keith KC to then read it to him
the WhatsApp has been taken of course
from the material which you've provided
and from obviously the phones from other
people who were interlocutors the same
if I may correct you Mr Keith what that
WhatsApp was was a a WhatsApp from the
cabinet secretary saying that he told me
directly something I don't think I saw
the WhatsApp directly to me Mark said
well on the 2nd of
July WhatsApp to you directly to
say lots of top draw people had refused
to come because of the toxic reputation
of your operation I'm sorry
look at his face rumbled Johnson also
claimed to have never been told that he
should advise people to stop shaking
hands when in fact his own scientific
advisers had warned him against shaking
hands on the very day that he boasted
about shaking hands at a hospital with
covid patients something that some of us
at the time said was complete Madness
the more Johnson spoke today the longer
his proverbial nose extended he denied
being told by his advisers that Co was
serious in the early months of 2020 he
was then shown this message from early
February in which his chief adviser
Dominic Cummings has clearly told him
the chief scientist told me today that
it's probably out of control now and
will sweep the world how much more
serious did it need to get he was also
shown this handwritten note from his
private secretary recording the prime
minister's words at a meeting in which
he said why are we destroying everything
for people who will die anyway bed
blockers you imagine anything more
repulsively insensitive about people's
loved ones than
that he was told that he simply didn't
think anyone would find out that was his
excuse but they did because it's an
inquiry and we're finding it all out now
it's hard to disagree with Simon casee a
senior civil servant quoted at today's
hearing who said he quote never seen a
bunch of people less suited to running
the country this was how Johnson
responded to that WhatsApp conversation
is um intended to be uh though clearly
it isn't uh femural um it it tends to uh
P to the pejorative and the
hyperbolical just Bluster Babble bull
crap he even attempted to tell us that
no matter what the facts say maybe he
did a pretty decent job after all in
many other countries
suffered terrible losses from covid they
did and the evidence that I've seen
suggests that we were well down the the
European table and and well down the uh
the world table the evidence before Mady
is that the United Kingdom had one of
the highest rates of excess
death in
Europe almost all other Western European
countries had a lower level of excess
death I've seen
just CAU again shaking his head he
couldn't believe the fact that someone
was calling him out on his lies well
since Boris Johnson still has such a
hard time with it let's make some things
crystal clear the UK's covid response
was an unmitigated Fiasco many thousands
of people died when they shouldn't have
because of his chaotic leadership and
government Boris Johnson famously hid in
a fridge to avoid an interview with me
well today he snuck into the co inquiry
in the early hours of the morning to
avoid facing the bereaved families who
were waiting for him outside later
unfortunately for him he was met by
jering heckling crowds when he left who
made their feelings very well known the
public knows Boris Johnson's Legacy even
if he doesn't he was a failed leader who
lied his way into and out of power with
deadly
consequences well I'm joined Now by Talk
tov's international editor Isabelle oak
shop by associate editor of the Daily
Mirror Kevin Maguire the broadcas and
biographer Tom B and the owner of
Crabtree Care Homes David Crabtree David
let me come to you first if I may
because I have spoken to you from the
start of the pandemic right to tonight
many times you've always been a very
eloquent and passionate uh articulator
of the real uh impact of the
government's policy decisions on care
homes in particular but when you saw
Boris Johnson today at the inquiry what
did you feel about his his evidence
I'm
so it just invokes the anger
again they were
incompetent big mistakes were made but
then to say are we risking everything
for people who were going to die anyway
forgetting
completely that the social Care staff
the mother of two had to go in there
with no PPE so he didn't even even today
he's not recognized that the social Care
staff saved the country but were put at
risk by this incompetent I'm sure they
must all go to some sort of rder school
because him and Hancock tell the same
lies they're just pathological in their
denial of and what's more annoying is
the reality is they'll all go on to have
a happy career and yet social carers are
still low paid still at risk and if a
pandemic happen tomorrow there is no
change I I have received no advice to
tell tell me anything different from
last
time you see that is absolutely
staggering let me bring in Isabelle
oakar because I think this has been one
of your bug Bears about the whole
inquiry is that it's not asking the
right questions and one of the key ones
is is how prepared would we be if we
were hit by another pandemic tomorrow
according to what David just said Care
Homes we're no better off than we were
the last time around well I think we've
learned quite a lot since then I don't
think you need to be issued with advice
to know that certain things would
definitely have to be done differently
um I'm afraid Piers I I think that your
summary of Boris Johnson's evidence
today was
spectacularly unfair and very very
biased now you know I hold no torch
whatsoever for Boris Johnson I have been
extraordinarily outspoken in my
criticism of the way he conducted his
administration particularly with
reference to the completely unjustified
Behavior inside Downing Street and the
lockdown parties but I was surprised
today to see him unusually Frank I think
he was quite honest and I know that's
not a normal State of Affairs for the
former prime minister but actually that
Contrition that he demonstrated I I
almost thought I was mishearing it but
you know this is a man whose career I
followed for 15 years I think that was
genuine he did nearly break down during
his evidence session today he did accept
responsibility and what he set out very
powerfully was how difficult it was to
make the judgments in his position where
he had to balance the whole not just
whether lives would be saved today and
tomorrow but the impact that shutting
down the whole of society would have in
the longer term we now know that the
consequences of lockdown were cat
catastrophic many many lives have been
lost damaged ruined destroyed as a
consequence of lockdown and that is what
he was wrestling with in the runup to
the first historic lockdown so far be it
from me to issue a defense of Boris
Johnson but I think your summary was
very very
unfair well that is a spectacular
defense of Boris Johnson it looks to me
like he's managed to pull the wool over
your eyes I'm equ Sur eyes cuz your eyes
your eyes are normally the toughest eyes
in Fleet Street so I'm pretty staggered
to hear you launching such a determined
attempt to do to deny what we just watch
with our own eyes and I'll bringing in
Kevin here I mean Kevin you were rolling
your eyes through that I just played a
series of Clips where Boris Johnson says
one thing and they then show him that
he's talking complete disingenuous
nonsense which is what he's done
throughout this now I don't deny for a
moment that we were in a very difficult
situation with this pandemic as was
every country in the world but I also
think on every conceivable metric from
testing from PPE from controlling our
border from the timings of a lockdown I
personally think without any vaccines or
therapeutic drugs there was no
alternative to lockdown the problem was
how the lockdowns got implemented and
how we didn't protect other people with
other diseases that was always the
problem and that again was a failure of
the government so I look at every single
way you could judge a government in a in
a health emergency and this this
government failed and watching Boris
Johnson today with somebody who looked
like he'd been brought finally to
account and just was trying to stammer
his way in that normal buffoon manner he
has to try and avoid proper
accountability yeah I watched the same
inquiry as you is Isabel saw a different
one other people may have watched the
same one as as Isabelle look he started
by apologizing he didn't really know
what he was apologizing for now he
wasn't tety he managed to re himself in
but he he strikes me like he's like a
boxer who's had the stuffing uh knocked
out of him he's punch drunk uh but he's
had months to prepare and he still
couldn't get his story straight as he
kept getting pulled up on in
inaccuracies denying truths which were
there quoted quoted at him now when we
get to the bit on the vaccine roll out
and the Jabs he may do a little better
because that was a success but you're
quite right early on the delayed
lockdown uh lost uh lost messages
WhatsApp I just don't buy that
disappearance at all but of course
that's when he was finalizing his
divorce and he was preparing to marry
again and he was just obsessed with
brexit so he took his eye off the ball
and people died as a result we saw there
were catastrophic failures the delaying
the lockdown what happened in Care Homes
M hanok described it as a protective arm
they didn't put a protective arm they
actually stopped testing instead of
expanding it there was no PPE for staff
so I I think you know you watch it and
you can only you can only judge I think
if you're just reasonable and of course
I don't like Johnson will admit but if
you look at it you got to think that we
were very unlucky to have him as a prime
minister because he was so inept and so
incompetent can I just pick up on one I
also think can I pick up on one of your
specific um accusations of Johnson there
I knew you would go very hard on him on
that note that we saw at the inquiry
today where he said why are we
destroying everything for people who
will die anyway very unfortunate
language he never expected that to be
public it was a private communication I
don't think it was unreasonable for him
to ask whether it was wise and it was
his job to have these uh mental um
balancing acts he had to make wasn't
unreasonable for him to ask that given
that the average age of those those who
died of let me finish those who died of
Co or with
were in their 80s so it was a reasonable
question for him to ask let me tell and
who when I hang on David David hang on
one sec as they were dying it was a
reasonable question
David David is run a series of Care
Homes where they literally take care of
people of that age that the lack of
compassion in that note and the fact
that you would defend that lack lack of
compassion
defending question I'm defending that he
phras it the way he did that
bed blockers why are we trying to save
these people I I very clearly did not
defend sorry when your sorry as we're
now discovering Isabelle when you're
prime minister of this country
everything that you say and do and write
in your term of office is for public
consumption that's why we're now reading
in a public inquiry in a way there is no
such private communication it doesn't
hurt anybody now neither here nor there
it is neither here nor there How It Was
Written now the question is whether he
it does I think it does it does because
I'll come to you in a minute D it
actually it's like the way it's like the
way he dismissed um long covid right and
and in a most dismissive and repulsive
manner I know people I had long Co for
several months but nowh near as badly as
other people I know who've been
literally crippled by it it's a hideous
thing that Afflicted about 20 to 25% of
people who get covid in varying degrees
and they see the Prime Minister dismiss
all people oh they can all die dismiss
long that do
that's
Ring very simplistic let me let me bring
in Tom B I've been waiting very
patiently Tom look we we've seen eye
rolling from Isabelle to me and Kevin I
rolling from Kevin to Isabelle where are
your eyes rolling on this well on all of
you I mean if Kevin had his choice we'd
have had we' had Jeremy Corbin as prime
minister he actually he actually
couldn't have done a worse job but the
whole point is this which everyone is
forgetting especially in the inquiry and
Keith is really a dreadful uh person and
H the judge a second rate criminal
lawyer shouldn't be given that job
either because what they're all
forgetting is this critical matter that
when this whole thing started it was
Valance on the 2nd of January who said
her immunity is the only way to cope
with it and it was public health England
led by a man who had not been successful
in the previous 13 applications for jobs
he had no a levels who got the job with
two women and they had no idea what they
were doing and that TR those three
people assured valence assured witty
assured the Prime Minister when he went
up to Collindale that they had
everything under control and so he was
relying on Experts and he was wrong to
do that and that is the problem that he
relied on the science and the scientists
had no idea what they were doing and
then yeah but Tom Tom I just want to say
one other Bas let me say one other thing
which I think puts the nail on this
inquiry the office of national
statistics which is the key uh
statistical operation of our country
produced a a graph which shows that
we're in the middle of deaths around the
world there is no way that Keith could
have produced the
inquiry statistics we showed that we
were amongst the highest if not the
highest he was quite simply wrong he was
quite simply wrong what he's doing is
what he's doing is he was taking the BBC
graph that they were pedaling throughout
this inquiry which was always wrong and
that is the whole problem with this
inquiry it is two people Keith who's a
real poser and a judge who think she's
terribly important and they got blaming
everything on brexit and Boris this
isn't a whitewash it's a black boils
down to you know what it boils down to
to me Boris Johnson won a massive
thumping election Victory on the back of
getting breit done which he didn't
properly get done uh and then he packed
his cabinet with people that agreed with
him which I always felt was a
fundamental failure of leadership put in
around you and they turned out to be the
most mediocre bunch of people from
Handcock to Rob to others you're you're
absolutely right he arrived in Downing
Street with a dreadful team of people
and as prime minister he had no idea
what government entailed all those
criticisms could be made of him and
they'd be true but the truth is that the
experts all got it wrong and he was
constantly briefed wrongly and the lock
down happened late because Valance and
witty and all of them couldn't agree and
then they delayed it themselves so you
know the problem with this inquiry is it
is the trial of Boris Johnson it is not
actually looking at the experts the
civil servants who were catastrophic
they built all these Nightingale
hospitals and there was nobody never
used them whatever happened to the book
stops at the top it's always always
somebody
else to be fair he accepted
that Boris Johnson had to be told it was
not a good idea to tell the public to
keep shaking hands that was in the
middle of mar that's a trivial thing
here that is utterly trivial trivial
trival that turned out to be how most
people caught the damn thing no it
isn't it was because of it was because
of Valance it was because of Valance and
witty that chelam went ahead it was
because of Valance and witty that the
football match in Liverpool went ahead
and that's the shaking of the hands what
the shaking of the hands ignoring the
advice and being flippant about older
people as it shows he just wasn't a
serious prime minister he just didn't
address it seriously there is an issue
about the advice he got and the experts
should not get off the hook either as we
look for how it happened and how we can
deal with it again but he was at the top
and he was just Cavalier in his approach
yeah he's a great campaigner but he was
absolutely rubbish as a prime minister I
agree with you Kevin he's a prime
minister this is the job he wanted the
one he craved his life and when it came
to the big the big challenge he failed
us David Crabtree final word to you on
this before these people in Care Homes
died 10 days before they died social
care workers had to care for them they
were put at risk by this
nonchalant non-treatment non PPE they
weren't regarded there was no
safeguarding of staff and the second
point is we did close our doors we were
made to open them to take back our
patients that were already in for
medical reasons untested the CQC and pH
England to Mr Bowers correct take no
responsibility and get away scot-free
with
this yeah thank you Dave well listen you
keep up your good work uh I want to just
before we leave you guys want to ask
Isabelle quickly about his breaking news
tonight uh that Remick has gone as
immigration minister in protest over the
uh
uh Robert jenck this is over the uh
Rwanda policy already a very
controversial policy how significant
will this be do you think to rishy sunak
tenure prime minister I think it is
extraordinarily significant I think this
is what you're seeing is the beginning
of a complete disintegration of this
government I really wonder how on Earth
he can pull things back together in
coming weeks and months because the
immigration problem isn't going away a
thousand people came came over in boats
in the last few days alone and we're in
the winter at this point so this is only
going to get worse for Rishi sunak and
there are an awful lot of MPS now who
are simply Tory MPS who are just out to
save their own skin and it's very very
difficult to run a government when
you've lost that level of
control Kevin yeah we are I agree with
Isabelle we're watching the
disintegration of a a government now of
course grik was pulling the strings he
was pushing for uh tougher tougher
controls to stop legal migration he
wanted to go further on Rwanda and defy
the European convention on human rights
and in a way the UK government is now
being outflanked by Rwanda itself which
is a repressive regime which says it
wants to abide by International norw
while I think it's shaming for the Tory
party the party of Winston Churchill
which crafted the convention on human
rights that they now want to defy but no
it's falling apart how long can they go
on well we might get nearly another year
of this because Prime Ministers do not
like to relinquish the keys to number 10
but the government is just falling apart
before our very eyes they don't but they
don't but Tom B very quickly uh this
conservative party has got a ruthless
streak in it as we've seen in recent
years they've toppled quite a few of
their their leaders and home secretaries
and others what's going to happen to
Rishi sunak now do you think well I
think it's too late to remove him but
I'm afraid I agree with my other two
panelists here it is the end of the Tory
party as we know it at the moment the
government really Rishi sunak isn't a
politician that's the real problem he's
a technocrat and um it really is
curtains that's sad sad point for
anybody who supports the Tory
party okay well we leave on a point of
of agreement with my panel which was not
looking likely about 10 minutes ago so
thank you all very much I appreciate it
and thank you David uncensor next the UN
Human Rights Chief condemns the
apocalyptic situation in Gaza I'll ask
Israel's ambassador to the United
Kingdom if she now believes there is a
humanitarian
[Music]
crisis we're here thanks for joining us
you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online R your smart speaker as well
criminals to using XL Bully dogs as
weapons to threaten others no matter how
well Tred most dog owners will tell you
a can turn do you know what I love about
talk today we do it all sunak sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the tor's love a scrap you
can almost see this coming around the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and richy soon at the other
the police are pro Palestine that is
just not right you swear an off in the
police to act without fear or favor the
co inquiry seem have turned into a sort
of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a
tragedy the amount of time it's taken
the number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million 140
million so far so40 million so far
results nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased news
going to come from in winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin book
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking if you're walking towards me and
you're a vegan you have a great big
orange sticker over here saying watch
out vegans
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in three years hundreds and hundreds of
mice in a box which he walks into a
branch of McDonald MC Mouse man MC Mouse
man MC mous man he should be easy enough
to catch this guy shouldn't he I mean
he's got house full of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz
Phil sunac and the current conservative
government are not conservative why
don't you leave that party and come to
one that actually shares your ideology
this has been a party political
broadcast on behalf of the reform UK
party kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solved
this is really unfair what what what's
unfair if it's on camera we're not doing
interviews yes I'm going to do you're
going to resolve yes course I cannot
continue my work when I say I am God I'm
not joking did you feel Elvis was
controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your questions are
you prepared to call h a terror group is
it possible to have a rational I've
asked you two questions should aass stay
in power and are they a terror group
you're refusing to answer either of them
that is very telling talk TV it's the
only place where you get the truth
you've done a book on poetry poetry and
music for the many I love poetry we can
agree on
[Music]
that welcome back to our sens of the UN
Secretary General today took the
unprecedented step of invoking article
99 of the UN Charter calling on the UN
Security Council to avert a humanitarian
catastrophe in gazer it comes after UN
Human Rights Chief vulka Turk described
the situation as apocalyptic with a
heightened risk of atrocity crimes last
time our next guest was on the show she
didn't accept there was a humanitarian
crisis in Gaza so I welcome back now to
zei hotelli who is the Israel ambassador
to the UK and I'll ask straight off the
top Ambassador if I may have you changed
your mind do you now accept there is a
humanitarian crisis in Gaza there is no
doubt there is humanitarian crisis in
Gaza but Kamas needs to be blamed for
that because just today we saw Hamas
taking over humanitarian Aid trucks
taking food from the people of Gaza
taking over every single thing including
medicine so this is Hamas behavior that
is preventing the people of Gaza to
receive this humanitarian Aid so we
still see Hamas as the main barrier to
give the people people of Gaza the
humanitarian Aid that Israel allows to
let to get into
Gaza but look I as you know I support
Israel's right to defend itself I think
Hamas by what it did on October the 7th
showed that it has to be removed and
they live amongst the civilian
population it's it's an incredibly
difficult War to prosecute if you're
Israel I accept all of those things but
the Stark facts are that over 15,000
people of now been killed in Gaza
already in just over two months of which
four to 5,000 are beli to be children
you cannot look at these scenes in Gaza
and not feel the same way that we all do
but this is a an extraordinary Slaughter
of innocent people as you go after
terrorists Pierce I totally doesn't
expect accept what you're describing at
the moment because think about how much
efforts Israel is doing to make sure the
Palestinians will get to a designated
areas in the southwest area of Gaza in
order to have a safer places shelters
humanitarian Aid all these things Israel
is doing something that not in the past
other countries did for enemy population
now we are dealing with a ter
organization that as a strategy use the
people and the children and the women as
human Shields so they're basing all the
the bases all their um military bases
inside hospitals they're basing it into
unra schools they're basing it into
masks and as you know now we are um in
kanun kanun is the city that this
archive terrorist that planned in in
this calculated way this devil plan of
October 7th so we now must finish the
job of making sure Hamas won't control
the Gaza Strip there is no other way if
you want a better future for Palestinian
children as well as Israeli
children where are where are all these
gazans going to live when this is over
you've pretty well leveled the north of
Gaza you're now going into the South to
do the same there you're shoehorning
these million several million people
into a tiny area where the facilities
for them are truly awful as every
independent assessor is saying but what
happens after this I mean if most of
Gaza gets destroyed and tens of
thousands of gazans are killed what life
is there left for them after this
well that's a very good question you're
actually referring to the day after the
war so first of there is still a big
task to Israel to make sure the
underground tunnel city is destroyed and
as I'm carrying this to remind everyone
there over
138 innocent people kept hostage in
Kamas hands including 15 women and by
the way it was Matthew Miller the
spokesperson of the state department
that said the reason Kamas didn't
release them in the last p is because
they're very much ter IED from the idea
these women will speak up for all the
atrocities the rape the systematic rape
Kamas committed against innocent women
and uh I really appreciate the fact you
spoke up for this sexual violence but I
want to tell you I feel sometimes like
Jewish women doesn't count when you
think about the world silence when you
think about un organization saying
nothing about the systematic rape Hamas
mutualized women it it it there was a
necrofilia there was uh innocent young
women from a music festival that had a
gang rape so those kind of things we
must make sure the world won't be
silenced about and and and I really
think that this was one of those moments
of Silence that was a disgrace to the UN
organizations and for many women
organizations by not speaking up for
that so I want to remind you that
because Kamas list didn't release our
hostages
list on on that I completely agree with
you but it's it's how Israel is going
about Prosecuting the war on Hamas that
is is causing increasing concern and it
is unprecedented for the UN Secretary
General to invoke article 99 of the UN
Charter they've never done it before uh
and this is because what he believes is
a a genuine right now safety security
and humanitarian threat which needs the
attention of the whole un Security
Council um you know this humanitarian
aspect of what is going on in Gaza is
now something that's requiring
unprecedented United Nations
intervention
well obviously this is not the case
because many times in the past there
were many types of humanitarian crisis
in many places do you think mosul didn't
look like Gaza after the Americans air
strikes do you think Tokyo after
American air strikes didn't look worse
than Gaza so over 100,000 Japanese got
killed in the second world war under
American air strikes and the reason it
was it was because the Japanese
involvement in Pearl Harbor so we need
to remember who started this war Kamas
started this war and this is not in our
duty by the way in in in no way not to
protect our people this is actually our
duty to make sure Israeli children will
prot protected in the future and no one
in the International Community including
our allies the Americans the British the
Germans no one is thinking there is
other way besides making sure Kamas
infrastructure won't exist the military
machine must be destroyed and you need
to remember that Hamas brought it on his
own people 16 years of Kamas regime
since 2005 no Israel control over G
Street and they B just poverty and
bloodshed over the Palestinian people at
the moment Ambassador we have Israel
giving us their version of what they're
doing in Gaza and the only journalists
outside of people actually in Gaza
nearly 60 of whom have been killed which
is horrific worst death toll on
journalists in living memory uh but the
the international journalists want to
get in there but they're only being
allowed in if they're with the IDF and
carefully controlled why won't you let
journalists go into Gaza and investigate
this as they would in other War zones
first of all I'm sure journalists will
be allowed into the Gaza Strip uh at the
moment remember that many parts of Gaza
are still controlled by Hamas and Hamas
is preventing from journalists to get in
and this is why IDF is actually giving
access to journalists to get in and to
see with their own eyes to be
eyewitnessing but only with the IDF and
again this is part of the reason why we
want to protect them we don't want them
to get caught in a crossfire but if
we'll go back to your question but the
argument is you know Ambassador just to
pick you up on that as you know what you
may be protecting as far as they're
concerned is access to reality and you
again I just ask you is it not time to
allow foreign journalists to go in there
without being escorted Everywhere by the
IDF where clearly there's a conflict of
interest there about what they may or
may not be prepared to there is
something that Israel doesn't have
anything to hide what we do is a self-
protection of our people after the BR
brutal attack at 7th of October but if
we'll go back to your question about the
day after one thing we realized after
ongoing military operations and this
time we wanted it to be final we don't
want it to be ongoing violence Cycles in
order to make sure both Israelis and
Palestinians will have a better future
there is no doubt the the Gaza Street
must be first of all demilitarized and
the second thing is it must be
deradicalized
when you think about the education
system under the UN symbol that brought
this young Palestinians to grow up to be
this monstrous terrorist we need to stop
that we need to make sure the next
generation will receive education of
respecting the other side just like
Israelis are raised an idea that in the
other side they are humans they they
must stop dehumanizing Jews and I I want
to tell you something I thought
anti-Semitism is out of this world when
I saw in 2023 the presidents of of us
you know ivy league universities still
don't understand well I'm going to come
to that the scale of anti I'm going come
to that with my I'm coming to that
specifically with my next guest actually
that's why I'm going to cut you off on
that Ambassador listen I appreciate you
coming back on the show I think we
should have a regular dialogue through
this war like I said to you you don't
have to you know justify October the 7th
in Israel's right to defend itself after
that it's it's how you're doing it that
is the matter of concern now and I
appreciate appreciate you coming on and
answering some questions thank you very
much very
much R sens next celebrated actor and
comedian John Lit is calling out a rise
in anti-Semitism including in Hollywood
and amongst as we just heard the
presidents of some of the most famous
ivy league universities in the world
what the hell is going on at these
[Music]
places we're here thanks for joining us
you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online on your smart speaker as well you
know what I love about talk today we do
it all sunak sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any your will because
he delivered the referendum that he said
he would deliver the tor's love a scrap
you can almost see this coming around
the tracks with sella bravman she's
heading up one side and richy soon at
the other the police are pro Palestine
that is just not right you swear an off
in the police to act without fear or
favor the co inquiry seems to have
turned into a sort of pantomim there's
not really any substance to it's hard to
know whether it's a fce or a tragedy
there needs to be one human per machine
to come and rectify beeps and the clanks
and when it goes wrong expected item in
bagging area I know are we only going to
be trusting sources like meta and Google
where is our unbiased news going to come
from Gram was president of the Cambridge
Union which is the rubbish version of
president of the Oxford
un Kevin O Sullivan is the worst
presenter on talk TV sitting on his fat
ass living if you're walking towards me
and you're a vegan you have a great big
orange sticker over here saying watch
out vegan's about Twitter you sons of
can you please reinstate my account
thank you this is a major Summit
President Biden decided this was
important after watching a Tom Cruz
film kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solved when I say I
am God I'm not joking did you feel Elvis
was controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your question are
you prepared to call h a terror group is
it possible to a
rational talk TV is the only place where
you get the
truth
this is talk
[Music]
TV welcome back to piss Morgan
uncensored I'm broadcasting from my home
as I still have covid uh yesterday's
been called the day us Academia died
after Congress cross-examined three
Elite University leaders on dealing with
anti-semitic protests on campus these
were some of their extraordinary
responses calling for the genocide of
Jews does not constitute bullying and
harassment that would be um investigated
of as harassment if pervasive and severe
specifically calling for the genocide of
Jews does that constitute bullying or
harassment if the speech becomes if the
speech becomes conduct it can be
harassment the answer is yes does
calling for the genocide of Jews violate
Harvard's rules of bullying and
harassment yes or no it depends on the
context it does not depend on the
context the answer is yes and this is
why you should resign these are
unacceptable answers across the board
what joining me now is the atan comedian
John LoveIt John uh good to have you on
the show I got to say I watched this
open mouth with utter horror what the
these are the presidents of the biggest
universities in America what what were
they doing failing to answer such a
basic
question it's it's h shocking and I
think it's because um
you know over the years everybody's
being put into a certain category you
know you're this you're that you're I
identifies as this and that as opposed
to everybody's you know has different
backgrounds but we're all people I was
in college in a dorm of Fine Art storm
and uh my friends and I were all
different and we'd tease each we'd make
fun of it because didn't mean anything I
was Jewish some were African-Americans
some were Chinese some were from
Mexico and um
we just said we were all friends we
didn't care we go isn't this exciting
you're going to be an actor you want to
be a singer you want to be a painter it
was about that it's just shocking to me
I mean if that isn't bullying what is
and if they said that about any other
well it's not bul I mean if you group if
if you hear people calling for right if
you hear about calls for genocide that's
not bullying or harassment that is
incitement to mass murder and
eradication of a people to another holog
course that's what it
means I agree
100% imagine if there was a group that
was in the
KKK and then they said that about
African-Americans which is would be
horrendous there's no question well
actually I was thinking today I was
thinking today if they were asked if
they were asked the same question about
similar attacks verbal threat attacks on
Muslims at universities for example what
would their reaction have been and I
suspect it would have been very
different and and that is I think one of
the uh really glaring inconsistencies
here is that when it comes to Jewish
students and how they should be
protected at University the same rules
don't
apply no I think there's a lot of uh I
think one of the sources of
anti-Semitism which has always been
around is the idea that they go I've had
people say to me they go oh you're the
chosen people you're chosen by God you
think you're better than everyone else I
go no and that's not what chosen means I
wish I get that out Jews don't try to
convert anybody you have to choose to
believe in the Ten Commandments choose
to do the right thing morally and
socially and also choose to listen to
The Voice in your head that tells you
the difference between right and wrong
so if you have a group of people doing
that you can't control them and people
that want to control other people that
drives them nuts you know but that I
think that chosen people thing is a big
uh Cornerstone of it and that's not what
joh if you've been struck by have you
been struck John by the lack of big
Hollywood stars who've put their their
heads above the parit to speak out in
favor of Jewish people right now many of
whom are feeling under real threat
around the
world yeah I am I mean the fact that I'm
on your show talking about it as opposed
to uh people that are much bigger than I
am I mean the ones that I see Talking
are um you know galado Wonder Woman
she's as Ry of course you going to say
something and Michael Rapa Port me and
Patricia Heaton who's on Everybody Loves
Raymond she's not Jewish but she's very
outspoken against anti-Semitism I don't
understand it I think the people they're
either scared or they're afraid to say
anything or they think it's going to
hurt their business but the I my what
should
happen so I was going to ask you John
what should happen to the Presidents of
these universities who were incapable of
saying that genocide represents even the
bar of bullying or harassment should
they all be
fired I think so yeah I mean you need I
mean if you can't stand up for right and
wrong how can you lead a university
where you're guiding young people
uh and teach teaching them this it's
just wrong it's not even like can they
go yeah of course it's
bullying I mean it it's it's ridiculous
it feels like the whole world it's
opposite day you know and that you can
be yeah it's so it's so surreal and
there such a double standard because the
the same universities were at the
Forefront of course after things like
the George Floyd murder in in taking
really Pro acve action there and yet
when it comes to what we're seeing with
the
anti-Semitism the action is the very
opposite of
proactive well I guess the the sad thing
about it
is what I'm realizing is the
anti-Semitism has always been there it's
just wasn't it wasn't out in the open
and now they've all come out in the open
and that's the the shocking part that
you think it would went away but of
course that's naive it's been around
since the existence of Jews for 5,000
years and to me it's just like oh my God
here we go again the the Germans the
Jews in Germany were German first they
couldn't believe it and I had the exact
same feeling and I realized here we go
again so I have to say something I'm not
political but I go I can't not say
anything it's about survival of of me my
friends my family my
relatives and as my dad sorry about my
voice as my father always said if Israel
goes all the Jews in the world they're
they're next that's it so I don't know
why people in Hollywood
aren't uh saying more I know about 700
of them signed a
petition but that that's well I'm glad
that you are speaking out uh John it's
important that people let you speak out
and don't worry about your voice by the
way because I've got Co which is why I'm
doing the show from home so my voice is
as bad as yours so we're in the same
boat but thank you very much for
you're my thanks for having
me all right all the best John LoveIt
and says the next Taylor Swift is named
Time magazine's person of the year does
that now mean she's the greatest pop
star of all time I would argue yes we'll
discuss after the
[Music]
break we're here thanks for joining us y
with talk TV on TV on radio online run
your smart speaker as well criminals to
using XL Bully dogs as weapons to
threaten others no matter how well
trained most dog owners will tell you a
dog can turn you know what I love about
to today we do it all sunak sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the tor's love a scrap you
can almost see this coming round the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and richy soon at the other
the police are pro Palestine that is
just not right you swearing off in the
police to act without fear or favor the
co inquiry seems to have turned into a
sort of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a
tragedy the amount of time it's taken
the number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million1 140
million so far so40 million so for
result nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased news
going to come from Kell in winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin book
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking if you're walking towards me and
you're a vegan she have a great big
orange sticker over here saying watch
out vegan's about the weirdest plank
that we've had in three years hundreds
and hundreds of mice in a box which he
walked into a branch of McDonald MC
Mouse man MC mous he should be easy
enough to catch this guy shouldn't he I
mean he's got house full of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz
film sunac and the current conservative
government are not conservative why
don't you leave that party and come to
one that actually shares your ideology
this has been a party political
broadcast
UK
part kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solve this is
really unfair what what what's unfair if
it's on camera we're not doing
interviews yes I'm going to do you're
going to resol yes cuz I cannot continue
my work when I say I am God I'm not
joking did you feel Elvis was
controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your questions are
you you prepared to call h a terror
group is it possible to have a Ral I've
asked you two questions should Hass stay
in power and are they a terror group
you're refusing to answer either of them
that is very telling talk TV is the only
place where you get the truth you've
done a book on poetry poetry and music
for the many I love poetry we can agree
on
that
[Music]
welcome back to PE Moran uncensored live
from my sitting room where I've got
covid so I'm doing the show from home uh
but I'm joined by my pack talk TV
contributor Esther krku and the podcast
from comedian James Bar welcome to both
of you right I want to talk Taylor Swift
who today was named Time magazine's
person of the year beating off a lot of
people from Vladimir Putin Vladimir
zalinski you know you could you could
put all sorts of world leaders in the
mix um but she uh was the winner Esther
are you a Taylor Swift fan should she
have got this Accolade and what does it
mean about her status in the pantheon of
Pop Idols well I'm not a Taylor Swit fan
just because I feel like if she was a
man she wouldn't get away with singing
about her exes in the way that she does
I find a uh very very uh like a drunk
white girl's dream oh come off it do
that all time I'm sorry I just you know
it's weird but she does deserve her
success she is now officially a
billionaire her her tour has raked in so
much money I mean her tour has created
many economic bubbles in areas that um
she's actually performed so that that is
a feat of her own but I do think it says
more about society that this is the
person that's uh woman of the year than
uh well person of the year than than
anyone else I would personally go
someone else but well you see all right
well let me bring in James now James you
and I have locked horns about Madonna
many times but on this we may find some
agreement because I actually think
Taylor Swift she's a brilliant sing a
songwriter I mean one of the best
there's been she is a fantastic role
model I mean you know you could if you
had a young daughter you would love her
to be a swifter because she represents
all that's wholesome and good about the
world right not not some of the idol
life some of these rap stars um but let
me finish with James but but James but
she's also turned out to be an
incredibly Savvy businesswoman I mean
she's generating vast amounts of cash
more I was told by someone in La she
makes more money than the Beatles prata
did right so there is a legitimate
argument she's now the biggest pop star
there's ever
been right I mean she's on 200 billion I
think U Madonna is on total sales of 300
billion Madonna has kind of hit her Peak
and I saw the celebration tour last
night it was slay but I think we
swifties know that Taylor Swift is not
really even at her Peak yet and is only
just emerging into that Peak period and
the eras tour is almost a best of so w
what is next take Swift is just an icon
and Esther I really think you need to
spend some time healing your heart and
listening to midnights because I know
from off air CH we both been going
through a little bit of a difficult time
you need some Taylor with what I would
say I would say this to Esther if if
James Bar and me agree about something
it is so unprecedented that you really
ought to join the
party I'm sorry Taylor Swift's dating
history is a complete dumpster fire if I
if she was my friend I would be like
ma'am we we need to talk um you need to
take a long break and stop singing about
your exes it's not cute strange it no
she listen Taylor can do whatever the
hell she wants and actually it is cute
because she is finally breaking the
patriarchal boundaries and say you know
what women are allowed to express their
feelings it's actually so patriarchal I
can't believe you're the peer Morgan on
the PE Morgan show right now Esther
because L Taylor Swift is look so good
she's calling out
a well I don't know about the you never
felt I've never felt so rough doing a
show I can tell you that oh yeah you win
some some here's the point Esther I
would make about her is that I I read an
amazing stat that not only did she sell
out this toour around the world a huge
stadiums night after night but the
merchandise average spend per fan who
bought a ticket was over
$230 ahead per person you could give me
her tickets for free and then she then
she released a movie of the of the
concert and that was one of the biggest
movie hits of the year I mean everything
she touches is gigantic well she is and
I think she she well the thing is her
brand is very is is is genius right
because she's very relatable she is
literally every drunk white girl's dream
she has terrible relationships she's not
perfect she's not hasn't had she a great
relationship I feel thing is she hasn't
had a lot of surgery done she is just
AAL word to J all right hang on don't
talk over each other final word to James
she's got a hunky new football star
boyfriend she's got it all now
right yeah she's walking around with her
next album ready to go when that
relationship may or may not end but
Taylor Swift is an icon she's amazing I
love her so much Esther I don't know
what music you're listening to but it
might be time to all right we got to
wrap it up James let's end while you're
on a high we agree Esther you're wrong
that's it for tonight keep it un sensed
good
[Music]
night
we're here thanks for joining us you're
with talk TV on TV on radio online onun
your smart speaker as well they have
made a statement condemning Hamas we
expect to see the crown revisit Harry's
anti-semitic Halloween costume criminals
to using XL Bully dogs as weapons to
threaten others no matter how well
trained most dog owners will tell you a
dog can turn you know what I love about
t today we do it all sunak sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the Israelis are very
conciliatory all they want is to be
recognized the timing of this hamus
attack comes because there was the
expectation there was going to be a deal
down so normalizing relations with Saudi
Arabia the Tories love a scrap you can
almost see this coming around the tracks
with sella bravman she's heading up one
side and richy soon at the other
reshuffles usually very dull this one
has booster Rockets attached to it
certainly the tone has shifted in terms
of what Rashi sunak has done the
question now is what he does next the
police are pro Palestine that is just
not right you swear an o in the police
to act without fear or favor the co
inquir seems to have turned into a sort
of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a tragedy talk TV
has spoken exclusively to a member of
the Blade Runners do you have a message
for sadique Khan we're not stopping
until you stop
the amount of time it's taken the number
of illegal migrants currently sent by us
to Rwanda zil the amount of money it's
cost we're saying what are we saying
it's cost about 140 million £140 million
so far so40 million so far result nil
absolutely nil are we only going to be
trusting sources like meta and Google
where is our unbiased news going to come
from Kell in winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corin
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking if you're walking towards me and
you're a vegan you have a great big
orange sticker over here saying watch
out vegan's
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in three years hundreds and hundreds of
mice in a box which he walks into a
branch of McDonald MC Mouse man mcmouse
man MC mous man he should be easy enough
to catch this guy shouldn't he I mean
he's got house full of
mice this is a major President Biden
decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz film